all right let's go to melissa in st
louis my husband and i have two children
we have a seven-year-old son and a
four-year-old daughter how long you've
been married as we get in
uh ten years ten years okay yes so as we
get into this age group we find
ourselves constantly teaching them about
honesty
and integrity and accountability you
know all those things that you want to
teach them
early in life so that they'll hopefully
be better off as they get older but my
husband and i have
i guess a secret of our own and we need
some help on how to
figure this out for our family okay um
so my husband has a son
from a one-time indiscretion that our
children do not know about
okay he's 14 years old and he lives with
his mother in another state
we provide full financial support to him
and we had about an eight-year
court battle to try to establish and
develop a relationship
it wasn't until he was 10 that the
courts mandated that
she produced the child and it was
revealed in court order therapy that she
had told him that his dad was dead
and a deadbeat all of those years as she
was
moving around changing her phone number
changing her name
just a very tumultuous type relationship
and we were kind of always two steps
behind her
um so once they started court order
therapy he traveled for a year he would
do one week a month
to do therapy and to visit and then at
the end of that year when the judge
asked
the child how he felt he just expressed
a lot of anger towards his dad
he didn't want a relationship with him
he didn't want a relationship with our
family
and the judge said that he was going to
honor that and that
if he wanted to when he was ready he
could come around okay
so we felt that we had exhausted all of
our options legally
financially um we incurred a lot of debt
um to make you know to meet that yearly
that monthly requirement
and emotionally we didn't really know
what else to do so we came to terms with
that we worked through that process and
obviously we hope that he'll come around
when he's older and ready to have that
conversation and we don't need to
involve the courts
um so i guess our question is you know
how do we tell
our two children about this at what age
is appropriate it's just causing a lot
of anxiety thinking of
opening up something so burdensome that
will leave this hole in their hearts
that they have this brother that
that they don't know but i'm also scared
to wait
until they're you know 30 and 28
and this kid shows up and he's their
brother and they had no idea yeah i
don't
find out that we kept this big secret
from them so yeah don't do that so i
don't want to figure out how
how to navigate that so i'm going to
answer two parts one you didn't ask me
and one
you did okay um i cannot recommend
enough
that your husband leave
a inexhaustible
trail of care and compassion
and intervention with this young boy
what that may look like right now
is a monthly or even weekly letter
that what you're doing is you're
building up months and years
of of i reached out i reached out i was
the grown-up i was the grown-up i was
the grown-up
there will come a moment when he's going
to want to talk to his dad it will
happen
and there will come a moment when he'll
see things clearly
it just happens that way and it might
not be till he's 30. it might not be
tough 21 there will be moments when he
wants to know
and that's when you want him to know
this guy reached out to me and would not
stop
what a kid is looking for is
that that never ceasing connection and i
cannot
get my feelings hurt by a 14 year old
with a manipulative mother
i can't get my feelings by 14 year old
period
there will come a day when your husband
can pull out all that paperwork and say
look this young man in the eye and say i
went to the ends of the earth for you
i want you to know that but i want this
kid to feel that
okay and so whether that's a
you send pictures of you you and him i
probably wouldn't include your
the two young ones yet um until he's
older
but i want him to know that y'all
reached out and reached out and reached
out and reached out
and one day he'll he'll he'll loop back
around i almost have no question that
will happen
the second part is this you have
a deep well of emotion tied to this
situation
right this kid means a lot to you i bet
if you
i bet you and i could talk offline in
person for about 15 minutes and you
could double over in tears right i mean
i bet it happened pretty quick
um your seven-year-old and your
four-year-old don't have that
they don't have that emotional
connection and all of that baggage and
all that pain associated with it
and so if you let them know you guys
have a brother
and daddy had another little boy
and he lives with another mommy in this
place
and you leave it at that then they will
go
oh one of them the oldest one may ask
can we go see and you'll say someday
and you just begin to norm it over time
the less sensationalized you make it the
more
fact-based you make it they don't have
the baggage you do they'll go
okay and as they get older they'll ask
questions about
daddy is another we have another brother
we have another son
and as they get older that's when you
can begin to have more and more open
conversation
right now the word indiscretion i don't
even like that word
but the word i know but i it just feels
so i know it doesn't know
it is but it is the um a seven-year-old
wouldn't understand what indiscretion
meant right right
he would understand um daddy has
um had another little boy that's older
than you
with another mommy and that mommy lives
in so-and-so
and hopefully one day we'll get to
everybody will get to play but he's
older than you right now
and your kid will go huh what's his name
and you'll say tom and you'll go oh
can i have some nachos right that's how
they'll absorb this story
okay and what what you don't want to do
is
communicate anything other than i'm just
telling you the truth
and as they age this conversation gets
deeper
and more whole and bigger i had a
conversation with my son
last night he's 10 now and we're talking
about integrity and honesty and i had to
tell him
your dad lied a lot when he was a kid i
was real insecure
and i just didn't tell the truth a lot
which is why i'm a lunatic about it now
and he couldn't have heard that at seven
at seven it was
daddy got in trouble a lot when he was a
kid you know what i mean right
and so again you just slowly open it up
like a funnel
but i think you are dead on i love your
heart here you can't have secrets just
destroy families
um if you have a picture if this
eventually there's a pen pal thing maybe
your husband puts a self
a dress stamped envelope in there and
gives this young kid an opportunity to
write him back
even puts paper in there and says i'd
love to hear from you i've put an
envelope in there you may lose that
envelope for five years
but it's year six that you get that
letter back right
and that letter may come back with just
a traced middle finger on it right
and right your husband just has to know
i'm not getting my feelings hurt by a 14
year old i'm just not
and i'm going to control we've sent some
we've we've sent some
um and in the beginning we used to send
cards and we would send gifts and we
sent all of these things and and it was
pretty much all rejected
um and so we recently found him on
a social media site yep and so he
reached out to him directly through that
um and so he just that's kind of been
you know he hasn't responded but again
trying to at least say i'm here when
you're ready to talk i'm you know
and again not talking at all about his
mother because we don't want it to be
that's right your mother is so horrible
and we are so great
um everybody has to answer for their
choices in this situation
and he'll figure that out really want to
figure out he will figure out deception
from mom he will figure out mom is not
who she said she was he'll figure out
why did we move 14 different places when
i was a kid he'll figure that out
and it may be that mom is rejecting
these letters you don't know
right it may be that mom is hitting
return on these things
and you have no idea the poison that
she's filling that poor little boy with
and it may be that one day you have a
box of letters that you
hand to him i hope you keep every one of
those things that gets returned hope you
keep
everything because at one point that
will be part of the conversation
and you just want um not only do you
want to trail
i don't want my husband giving up on his
son
right i don't be married to that guy so
i want him to continue it sounds like
he's not right i'm not putting that out
there but no
he's going for it and going for it go
for it reach out on social media that's
always
a paltry chick and crap second option
right and not it's just not a way to
communicate with with people that you
love
always be sending cards always be
sending letters i love just handwritten
letters man
and um keep sending them keep sending
them keep sending them and she may burn
every one of them
great it's not going to hurt him but
yeah
your original question yes you got to
tell the little kids and i would
tell them in a way that preserves
everybody's dignity right now
doesn't let them be surprised and maybe
you introduce it with a photo and
kind of like my daughter she's five we
like she curls up and looks at old photo
albums and look this is when you were in
mommy's tummy
it may be you know who that is that
little boy is your brother
that's your brother daddy has another
son who's way older than you with
another mommy
and they'll go how does that work then
you may have to explain some stuff
but you can start it so they'll have a
picture in their head and they're just
going to go on about their day
and never never lie to your kids um
tell them the truth i love your heart
melissa this is a hard one this is a
tough one
um but lean into the hard conversation
it's gonna be hard and lean
don't give up chasing that little boy